on your quest to find a soulmate it's
expected that you would cringe at the
idea of finding beauty and a beast but
we were all for Belle falling in love
with a water buffalo so what are the
issues with bestiality anyways what
would actually happen if you had sex
with an animal before you start flirting
with Huskies on the street but high
logical mechanisms are in place to
prevent sex between different species if
two different species sperm and egg
can't even fuse this is called a
prezygotic mechanism examples are of two
species have been compatible sex organs
that won't fit two species live in such
different locations that they can never
bang or they have different mating
rituals so are never even interested in
trying even if two different species end
up managing to have sex it's unlikely
the sperm and egg would produce an
offspring in the case of bestiality with
you and a closely related species like a
baboon one study showed that human sperm
couldn't attached to the protein surface
of the eggs of baboons therefore there
would be no fusing and the first phase
of fertilization could never be
completed now part baboon part human
babies will ever roam this planet but in
some cases a successful offspring can be
produced by different species for
example male lions and female tigers can
produce a liger this is where post
psychotic mechanisms come into play
these are mechanisms that prevent the
survival of an inter bred offspring for
instance when you cross a horse and a
donkey you likely end up with a sterile
mule so the mule exists but can't have
babies itself other postzygotic
mechanisms include hybrid inviability
when a successfully fertilized egg
doesn't develop past early stages or
hybrid breakdown where the offspring
itself can have kids but generations
after are sterile and incapable of
producing children all in all prezygotic
and post psychotic mechanisms ensure
that if different species do have sex
it's hard for them to successfully
reproduce but sometimes animals labelled
as different species can still mate
because they share a relatively recent
and
like when us Homo sapiens made it with
Neanderthals the hypothesis is that
female humans breeding with male
Neanderthals were able to generate
fertile offspring but female
Neanderthals who made it with male
humans were either rare absent or
infertile
there are many conflicting theories
about why and how we hooked up with
Neanderthals but one reason may have to
do with the fact that they are kind of
following being a human who engages in
bestiality comes with dangers one study
shows that males who had sex with
animals were at a higher risk for penile
cancer than males who didn't this is
probably because micro traumas on the
penile tissue are produced during sex
this exposes the human tissue to animal
secretions and other infectious agents
that can lead to cancer several other
case studies show colorectal trauma and
harmful bacterial infections are also
possible after sex with an animal
so yeah why do people do it one study
identifies several motivations for
bestiality for instance there are maybe
situational reasons where people have
limited access to human partners or
financial incentives where people have
sex with animals for pornography or for
sex shows there may also be cognitive
impairment emotional immaturity and
dopamine dysregulation motivating the
act as well and there are some reported
cases of zoo files who feel affection
and intimacy with an animal with one
case study showing a man who left his
wife in order to live with horses he had
affection for so it turns out Belle
wasn't the only one who fell in love
with the Beast
clearly this video was not sponsored and
at this moment in time it's probably
demonetized to someone else so we're
gonna take this time to tell you about
our new podcast sidenote which we learn
every week we take on controversial
topics like this one and then we
Fleiss in the science information so
that you are entertained while
simultaneously learning you might not
know this but surprisingly Mitch and I
disagree on a lot of things and that
comes out in this podcast pretty
evidently so make sure you subscribe to
it wherever you can it's called side
note and we'll see you next week for a
new science video the